bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour la suite et fin de ce cours sur la
bio stratigraphie du car ou alors la
dernière fois nous avions commencé notre
voyage tout au sud ouest du pays
au cap dans la ville du cap et nous
étions remontés jusqu'à länder dont nous
avions rencontré le douik a donc des
pogos la sierre et les cas les dépôts
mara du début du quart ou du début du
permien de la faim petit peu la fin du
carbonifère aussi les débuts du permien
puis nous étions remontés vers maire de
revel où nous étions passés à travers la
zone a et audi sinon d'eau que vous
voyez ici la toute première biozone du
carreau puis la zone à tapis noke
phallus
nous étions ensuite remonté direction
bouffantes ouest où nous avions
rencontré la zone a en d'autres shows
dont donc la première biozone après la
première grande crise d'extinction que
le carreau a connu la crise de la fin du
gwada loupien ensuite nous étions
remontés à melesse bergues où nous
avions rencontré la zone à qui ce téké
phallus qui est le caroux très typique
on va dire et enfin nous étions arrivés
entre goldberg et bloemfontein à la zone
adapte aux quais phallus qui est la
dernière biozone du permien donc en fait
ne nous étions arrêtés pile ici à cette
limite entre le gris foncé entre le vert
foncé le vert clair qui correspond en
fait à la limite permise trias donc là
c'est pareil on peut avoir l'impression
que la limite permise trias est très
très bien représentés tous partout dans
le karoo elle a vu de cette longue
longue longue limite permise trias que
vous pouvez voir là en réalité les
sections les véritables affleurements
avec des sections au niveau de la limite
permise trias sont très très rares
en réalité il n'y en a pas tant que ça
il y en a quatre qui sont vraiment très
très bien connu une du côté de raf
reinette donc
il y en a une ou deux du côté de raf
rennais temps dans le sud du pays
et ensuite quand vous remontez voilà du
côté de cold burg et de bloemfontein y
en a encore quelques unes en a une qui
est vraiment tout près de bloemfontein y
en a une autre qui est pas loin de cold
bug et donc on en a redécouvert une
autre il n'y a pas longtemps aussi du
côté de cold bug à ovi store
donc il ya beaucoup de il ya beaucoup
d'endroits en fait où on pourrait croire
que la limite permise atria ça va
présenter mais en réalité des vraies
belles sections à travers la limite
permise trias y en a pas tant que ça et
c'est d'ailleurs en afrique du sud c'est
à peu près à des seuls endroits où vous
pouvez voir une limite permise trias en
milieux continental la localité type de
la limite permise trias elle est en
chine
ils ont fait un espèce de monuments
absolument gigantesque d'ailleurs à la
gloire de la limite permise trias là bas
c'est assez marrant
donc la localité type elle se trouve en
chine mais c'est une section marine en
fait donc c'est dans l'environnement
marin
ici en afrique du sud nous ce qu'on a
c'est à peu près la seule section des
seuls section en milieu de terrai str
donc c'est le seul endroit où on arrive
à voir ce qui se passe en milieu
terrestre est donc là où c'est assez
amusant c'est que quand on compare à
l'extinction en milieu marin en fait
l'extraction en milieu terrestre
elle a pas l'air si terrible que ça en
tout cas et si on la compare en plus à
la limite à la halle à l'extinction de
la fin du gwada loupien en fait
l'extinction de la fin du gwadloup ya
beaucoup plus touchées les faune
terrestre que ne le fait la limite
permise trias donc c'est peut-être aussi
parce qu'il restait plus grand-chose à
tuer mais mais en tout cas voilà c'est
assez marrant en fait de voir comment le
comment en fait les limites les ce type
pardon d'extinction de masse sont
interprétés et sont étudiées d'ailleurs
il ya eu il ya pas longtemps
une étude qui réinterprétait
l'extinction de la fin de l'extinction
des dinosaures comme un d'éclat suivi
d'un coup de grâce par la météorite plus
volcanisme pour l'interrogation et du
coup s'il y en a beaucoup qui ont réagi
voir sur réagi à ça je pense notamment à
faux s'il vous plaît ça lui qui est
vraiment en contre
l'idée du déclin qui s'est vraiment très
fortement exprimés contre l'idée du
déclin et je pense que c'est un peu une
sur-réaction dans mon en tout cas pour
moi parce que ce qu'au final enfin quand
on est sur le terrain et qu'on regarde à
quoi ressemblent les limites ce genre
d'extinction sur le terrain c'est très
très très très ouvert à l'interprétation
quoi
déjà c'est hyper sensible à la taxonomie
c'est hyper sensible à la façon dont on
interprète aussi l'extinction c'est
hyper sensible à la quantité d'endroits
où on peut voir l'extinction vraiment en
vrai voilà c'est hyper sensible c'est
enfin je ferai une vidéo exprès pour
expliquer ça je pense d'ici la rentrée
dit si d'ici le mois de septembre je
pense que je ferai une vidéo extrait
quand j'aurai fini de lire déjà
l'article
parce que j'ai pas fini de lire
l'article sur ceux qui proposent que les
dinosaures était sur le déclin mais il
faut bien voir que si les débats sont si
vif
en fait c'est ça qu'il faut voir c'est
que les débats sont vifs pour savoir si
les dinosaures était sur le déclin ou
pas est la raison pour laquelle les
débats sont vifs c'est parce que les
données de base sont pas claires faut
bien se dire qu'il n'ya pas un message
clair donné par le registre fossile de
base le registre fossile de la limite
par exemple de la limite crétacé
tertiaire
il est essentiellement limités à des
trucs en amérique du nord et en asie
vont pas dire avec un biais très franc
pour l'amérique du nord d'ailleurs donc
donc tout ce qui se passe dans
l'hémisphère dé l'hémisphère sud
globalement ça passe à la trappe dès que
vous vous posez la question de ce qui se
passe à la limite permise à trias
crétacé-tertiaire pardon vous tout ce
qui se passe dans l'hémisphère sud passe
à la trappe
voilà deux là c'est
donc c'est quand même c'est quand on
s'assoit déjà sur un gros paquet de
données
et ça c'est pas c'est pareil je veux
dire amérique du sud afrique australie
on ne sait pas ce qui s'y passe à la
limite permise adrian à la limite
crétacé tertiaire je vais y arriver
bon bref donc déjà ça c'est un premier
billet le deuxième billet c'est qu'on
peut pas utiliser tous les groupes de
dinosaures qu'on veut parce que bah
évidemment il ya des groupes de
dinosaures on en trouve déjà plus au mas
triche ira ça veut pas dire qu'ils
n'étaient pas là mais en tout cas on en
trouve déjà plus le typiquement les
alvarezsauridés les alvarezsauridés on
en trouve aux campagnes 1 on en trouve
déjà plus beaucoup en campagne 1 et au
mas très chiant n'a quasiment plus
pourquoi et du coup on se pose la
question faut-il les inclure ou faut-il
des les exclure dans l'analyse si on les
inclut on va forcément avoir un signal
qui va fortement penché vers un déclin
des dinosaures avant leur extinction
mais en même temps est-ce que c'est pas
parce que éventuellement le groupe des
alvarezsauridés on l'a on s'est rendu
compte qu'il existait qu il ya trente
ans en réalité est ce que ça vient pas
de là le problème
voilà et que du coup on a beaucoup moins
de données que pour des groupes comme
les tyrannosaures aux ide ou c'est
littéralement un des premiers groupes de
dinosaures qui a été découverte et donc
il ya des choses comme ça qu'il faut
prendre en compte
donc voilà mes frères je ferai une vidéo
exprès pour pour bien expliquer ça est
et dans le contexte justement de la
limite permise trias j'essaierai de vous
montrer comment c'est ici en afrique du
sud pour la limite père vient trias et
du coup histoire d'extrapoler un petit
peu pour la limite crétacé paléogène
donc aujourd'hui on va parler de la
limite permise trias après cette discret
cette petite digression mais c'est une
digression par rapport à l'actualité
c'est aussi quelque chose qui est
important quand on fait cours de parler
de l'actualité de montrer que le terrain
les vivants quoi que il ya de l'activité
et qu'il ya du débat
donc ça fait partie des cours donc
aujourd'hui la limite permise un trio on
commence avec la limite permise à trias
et puis on va passer sur toutes les
pièces jaunes du trias et les bio zone 2
du début du jurassique jusqu'à la fin du
quart ou des dépôts du caroux qui se
termine comme je voulais dit la dernière
fois par le drakkar berg l'éruption du
michael berg qui va sceller le bassin
avec des bas des basaltes et bassin qui
va être protégés du coup de l'érosion
jusqu'à la trêve ça monte jusqu'à
quelques millions d'années
donc voilà la limite permise à trias
donc déjà ce qu'il faut savoir à propos
de la limite permise trias c'est
qu'effectivement c'est l'une des plus
grands une des plus grande crise
d'extinction de masse de l'histoire de
la vie c'est une des plus grandes 2 est
plus importante
extinction de masse de l'histoire de la
vie probablement les événements de
l'histoire de la vie qui a eu le plus
d'impact
finalement sur la vie elle même depuis
son apparition
donc déjà ça c'est un truc qu'il faut
quand il faut bien se rendre compte
qu'il faut bien visualiser et pourtant
comme je vous le disais elle a peut-être
pas eu autant d'influencé que ça sur les
rangs tout cas elle a probablement pas
eu autant d'influencé sur les faunes de
tétrapodes sud africaine que ne l'a eu
la crise de la fin du gwada loupien
c'est vous dire l'intensité de la crise
guadeloupéenne parce qu'il ya quand même
82% des genres de tétrapodes qui se sont
éteints comme indiqué ici ça c'est
pareil c'est aussi un truc qu'il faut
prendre en compte on compte pas le
nombre d'espèces généralement quand on
estime quand on estime le nombre de la
quantité d'extinction qui a eu lieu
généralement on regarde les genres et
les genres c'est déjà un niveau
différent des espèces mais bref c'est
pareil j'en reparlerai en détail la tout
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'en gros
bas une grande partie de ce qui existait
avant va disparaître à la limite permise
trias et en afrique du sud ça va se
manifester
selon une certaine quantité de symptômes
alors qu'ils sont résumés dans ce
tableau là si vous êtes très intéressé
par les détails mais là on va résumer ça
dans les grandes lignes dans les grandes
lignes
et encore une fois dans un contexte bio
stratigraphique c'est-à-dire dans un
contexte de terrain quand vous vous
baladez dans ces alternances marno
gréseuses comment est ce que vous voyez
en fait la limite permise trias dans ces
alternances marno graisseuses mais déjà
la première chose qu'il faut savoir avec
la limite permise trias en afrique du
sud c'est que quand vous vous baladez
dans les heurts dans les alternances
marno gréseuses de la limite permise
trias c'est que la limite permise atria
on ne la voit pas la première chose à
savoir sur la limite permise trias c'est
que contrairement à la limite crétacé
paléogène elle n'est marqué par rien il
n'y a pas un petit niveau dargis noir
comme il ya le crétacé paléogène et
encore ce niveau dargis noir n'est pas
partout mais si vous allez à biarritz
par exemple vous pourrez le voir ce
niveau dargis noire parce qu'il y ait à
biarritz à la limite crétacé paléogène
mais ici en afrique du sud quand on
regarde la limite permise trias 252
millions d'années vous collez votre nez
dessus il ne se passe rien voilà donc et
pour illustrer sa je vous ai mis cette
photo alors cette photo c'est une photo
qu'on a prise quand cédric était là
normalement vous devez voir cédric
jurassique qui se trouvent ici voilà et
donc quand cédric est venu eh bien on a
pris cette photo de groupe à cet endroit
là est la raison pour laquelle on a pris
assez danton à cet endroit là c'est
parce qu'il ya un fossile au milieu
quelque part je sais plus exactement il
me semble qu'il est là au pied de marque
donc il y avait un beau fossiles et puis
l'affleurement était jolie et puis tout
le monde était là c'est pas souvent sur
le terrain que tout le monde est là
généralement se sépare en groupe et
chaque groupe va chercher les fossiles
un peu dans son coin là tout le monde
était réuni on s'est dit on va faire une
belle photo de groupe sur un
affleurement ça va être beau ça m classe
et il se trouve que un an plus tard
n'ont même pas deux ans plus tard un an
plus tard si un an plus tard en fait on
s'est rendu compte que la limite crée
pas les la limite permise trias parlons
eh ben elle passait juste là en fait on
se tenait littéralement sur la limite
permise trias la limite permise à trias
elle est là entre cette couche rougeâtre
rougeâtre violet âtre et 7 rouges bleues
grisâtre en fait elle se trouve ici la
limite permise trias et on ne s'en était
pas rendu compte
on s'en est pas rendu compte pourquoi
parce que la limite permise atria se
trouve au milieu d'eux au milieu du
membre palin khlouf de la formation je
crois que c'est la formation balfour
donc elle se trouve elle se trouve au
milieu en fait d'une unité géologique
donc vous avez ces alternances barnaud
gréseuses là comme vous pouvez le voir
ici
ces alternances marno gréseuses alors la
palène khlouf elle est un peu plus c'est
un peu plus de la meute stone donc c'est
un peu moins marneux et c'est un peu
plus c'est un peu plus de l'argile en
fait
mais bref ça ça change pas grand chose
au fait qu' elle se trouve en plein
milieu d'une couche d'argile en fait
donc on la voit pas cette limite permise
trias et ça c'est la première chose à
savoir donc là pour le coup pour
localiser la permière la limite permise
trias la biostratigraphie est d'une
importance capitale
vous ne pouvez pas faire autrement elle
est quasiment indétectable du point de
vue purement géologiques
c'est là où je veux en venir à tel point
que on a eu beau se tenir dessus le jour
de cette photo on était là on est restés
des heures sur cette affleurements on ne
l'a pas vu et c'est seulement quand on a
commencé à trouver des fossiles qui sont
des marqueurs typique de cette limite
permise trias qu'on a commencé à se
rendre compte que en fait il y avait une
limite permise trias à ce renvoi là et
ça a donné lieu justement à la vidéo que
j'avais upload et l'année dernière où
justement on était revenu à cet endroit
là et on était parti à la recherche de
cette limite permise trias donc deux
choses permettent de dire qu'il s'agit
de la limite permise trias c'est que
d'une il va y avoir les changements
fauniques et floristiques que dont je
vais vous parler juste après et la
deuxième chose c'est la date la date
donc on a un âge qui a été indiqué par
des zircons qui sont hélas ce désir
qu'ont détritiques donc il ya une grosse
marge d'erreur sur saisir con mais qui
correspond 252 millions d'années ce qui
est la date qui a été obtenu en âge
absolue grâce sur la section de base qui
se trouve en chine
la section typique qui se trouve en
chine donc ici on a un changement de bio
zone donc un changement biozone qui
indiquent un changement phonique
on passe de la zone adapte aux quais
phallus à la zone a10 trop aux russes
des clis la zona liste rose aux russes
comme on l'appelle gêné
non c'est juste que dire que c'est la
zona liste rose russe en fait il ya un
tout petit risque de confusion avec la
soul zone a10 trop aux russes moscow
rinus mais enfin bronze si je vous parle
de zona liste rose aux russes c'est la
biozone à l'isro zaurus des clés vis à
partir de maintenant et donc à cette
limite et cette limite ça aussi ce qui
est illustré ici ce qui est visible du
coup c'est que comme vous voyez on est
au milieu du membre pallem khlouf de la
formation balfour comme je vous le
disais donc on est vraiment sur une
géologiquement la litho vous voyez que
la biostratigraphie vous dis qu'on est
sur une zone de changement la litho
stratigraphie elle par contre elle vous
indique que rien du tout c'est
exactement ce que je vous ai illustré
tout à l'heure donc il ya plusieurs
raisons pour laquelle on va arriver à
savoir qu'on se rapproche en fait de
cette limite permise trias et la
première ça va être les listes rose aux
russes les listes rose aux russes qui
donc les listes on autorise déjà c'est
un genre de dissin aux dons qui est très
connu pour traverser la limite permise
trias je vous ai parlé la dernière fois
donc de liste rose aux russes du gros
liste rose russe liste rose horus mât
cay qui apparaît dans la zone adapte aux
quais phallus et qui commencent à
indiquer le début de la fin pour le
permien est bien celui stromae russe
macheda et qui est celui de gauche le
gros liste rose aux russes c'est pas le
même que le lis trop riche du trias qui
se trouve à droite le petit bistrot rue
ce qu'on appelle le liste rose russe
maria y est donc liste rose aux russes
macheda et le gros et liste rose aux
russes maria et le petit sont
symptomatiques de ce qu'on appelle
l'effet lille but est l'effet lilliput
donc des difficultés du voyage de
gulliver en fait c'est laid c'est que
pendant une extinction pendant une
grosse crise d'extinction les espèces
enfin les taxons qu'ils vont réussir à
traverser la crise très souvent vont
être ceux qui vont réussir à développer
des adaptations à cette crise logique
autrement il aurait pas survécu et ces
attaques parmi les possibilités
d'adaptation à une crise biologique
il y a l'effet lilliput qui est
réduction de la taille ce qui permet
d'économiser
ressources et aussi d'augmenter la
vitesse de d'augmenter de diminuer on va
plutôt dire ça comme ça de diminuer le
temps entre chaque génération est donc
d'augmenter le nombre de mutations
possibles et donc l'adaptabilité de
votre espèce quand vous devenez plus
petits vous vous reproduisez plus vite
votre maturité sexuelle arrive plutôt
dans votre développement et du coup vous
reproduisez plus vite du coup il ya plus
de chances que vous développiez des
mutations avantageuse d'une génération à
une autre donc et en plus vous
économisez encore une fois les
ressources donc vous devenez basiquement
vous passez d'un si vous connaissez un
peu vos notions d'écologie c'est comme
transitionner d'un stratège
qu'a donc un stratège spécialisé à un
stratège
r c'est à dire un stratège rapidité de
reproduction et généraliste donc c'est
un peu ça c'est un écologiste va
m'engueuler dans les commentaires de
maintenant je les 10 mai mais voilà
c'est si vous avez des petites notions
d'écologie faut que vous représentez un
peu ça c'est à dire que le gros liste
rose horus mât cay il était c'était
certainement un spécialiste dans un
environnement dominé par d'autres disent
innocente typique de la zone adapte aux
quais phallus arrivée la limite permise
trias bain d'un seul coup il s'est
retrouvé tout seul et il s'est retrouvé
dans un environnement extrêmement
perturbé et ben il est laid distro aux
russes sont réduit en taille et cette
réduction de taille s'est accompagnée
d'une augmentation de la population
augmentation de la reproduction et voit
la multiplication des chances du coup
d'arriver à tomber par chance sur les
bonnes mutation qui permettront de
survivre un petit peu plus longtemps et
ça a fonctionné avec liste rose aux
russes parce que liste rose aux russes
après il a donné son nom à la vie aux
autres suivante c'est vous dire ainsi ça
va bien fonctionner quoi donc pendant
les quelques millions d'années qui ont
suivi bistrot aux russes ça a été le
taxon dominant pour ne pas dire que
c'est la seule chose qu'on trouve
et ça aussi c'est là c'est une autre
chose qui est importante quand on
travaille cela limite ce permien trias
donc avoir la limite permise trias on va
trouver beaucoup de gros d'ici nos dont
tu lis trop horus mât cay évidemment
mais aussi d'apt ok phallus
dicillo dont 10,6 naudon c'est un peu
avant la même beaucoup avant la limite
permise trias mais on va trouver d'apt
ok fallu ce qui est relativement gros et
on va trouver plein d'autres gros d'ici
nos dons des gros herbivores et on va
trouver aussi des gros carnivores comme
les gorgones obtient rugby jean par
exemple et d'un seul coup il ya la
limite permise trias enfin on ne voit
pas cette limite permise trias par
contre en tant que paléontologues d'un
seul coup vous allez vous mettre à
trouver que des listes roseaux russe par
tous comme des dictons d'ailleurs donc
ramené dit on à l'époque quand on
parlait de la zone a en octobre voilà
c'est un peu pareil d'un seul coup vous
allez vous mettre à trouver que des
listes roseaux russe partout et des
petits en plus même pas des gros et là
vous savez que vous êtes passés dans le
trias en fait donc sur le terrain c'est
comme ça que ça se ressent en fait vous
êtes dans un environnement où dont vous
êtes par le membre par un clou favec
c'est interdit dans ce 2e match tonnes
et 2 et 2 et degrés et d'un seul coup
vous vous passez d'un moment vous
trouviez des gros dicillo dont des gros
ossements et d'un seul coup trouvé plus
que des petits ossements et tous des
listes roseaux rouges voilà vous savez
que vous avez franchi la limite permise
trias en fait c'est comme ça que vous
arrivez à localiser votre limite permise
trias en remarquant en fait ces
changements dans la vie dans la faune en
fait c'est les changements dans la faune
qui vous vous indiquer ses chances que
vous avez passé la limite permise trias
et en en augmentant en fait ventre
échantillonnage et en rétrécissant
l'espace entre chaque échantillon va
vous finissez par an dire ok la limite
permise trias c'est là qu'elle a lu
voilà enfin l'extinction permettre csc
de laquelle à lui et donc ça se voit
rien qu'au bistrot russe bien qu'à vu de
l'historique ça se voit et cette limite
permise trias que je vous montrer un peu
plus tôt la salle où ils sont en train
de se tenir
c'est comme ça qu'on s'en est rendu
compte en fait c'est quand on a commencé
à trouver des gros lisse trop riches en
bas de la colline et des petits bistrots
russe en haut de la colline qu'on s'est
dit attendez là il put effect la haye
avoir une limite permise trias ici
ensuite il ya un changement floristique
aussi à la limite permise
on passe d'un monde qui est dominé par
les glochos pteris qui sont des sondés
gym nos enfin qui sont des plantes qui
sont proches des gymnospermes et qui ont
des grandes feuilles ici avec une grosse
nervures médiane comme ça à une faune
qui est dominé par lesdits chromium et
l'éthique rhodium c'est des feuilles qui
ressemble beaucoup plus à des à des
feuilles de fougères et qui ont 7 7
ramure ramifications en deux comme ça ça
c'est très très typique de dhikr oïdium
alors c'est ce qui lui donne un nom
indique rhodium ça vient de deux parce
que à chaque fois vous avez cette
ramification en 2 donc ses feuilles de
qui ressemblent à des feuilles de
fougères qui se ramifiant de traits
typiques de dick royaume donc la flore
aussi changent à la limite permise trias
vous avez une flore dominé par gosso de
teris vous allez vers une flore dominé
par dick ruiz y sommes c'est plus
difficile à repérer généralement il ya
une section permien trias en afrique du
sud où il y a plus de fossiles de
plantes que de fossiles de vertébrés et
où donc on utilise ça comme marqueur il
ya une section en afrique du sud bien
sûr les quatre ou cinq qu'on connaît on
a aussi un changement de prédateur c'est
vrai que tout à l'heure j'ai parlé
beaucoup des des herbivores mais il ya
aussi un changement dans le prédateur
comme je voulais dit les prédateurs
dominant du la fin du permien ce sont
les rubis jean et les gros gorgone
obtient rugby jean et ils disparaissent
à la limite permise trias et d'un seul
coup on a un nouveau entrée en lice
s'est protégé au suc us et c'est
l'entrée en lice aussi des archosaures
les archosaures n'existe pas en afrique
du sud avant la limite permise trias
c'est pile sur la limite permise t as
arrivée d archosaures donc ça fait
partie aussi que ces changements
phonique qui ont lieu à la limite
permise trias les archosaures n'existe
pas avant on à arques aux russes qui est
le plus vieil archosaures qui a lieu
légèrement avant la limite permise trias
en russie mais sinon en afrique du sud
c'est pile à la limite permise trias
qu'ils arrivent on a aussi un changement
dans les milieux de dépôt la limite
permise trias c'est aussi en afrique du
sud un changement de
de climat donc il ya un changement de
climat une aridi fication du climat qui
s'accompagne d'un changement dans les
milieux de dépôt à savoir que les
rivières qui étaient autrefois des
rivières méandreuse avec des grandes
plaines d'inondation deviennent
maintenant des rivières plus droite et
avec dvd avec des chenaux qui
s'entrecroisent ont ce qu'on appelle des
rivières en tresse des rivières très c
est donc ce changement va entraîner des
changements dans les milieux de dépôt
qui vont passer d'un milieu plus
réducteur avec des fossiles qui sont
préservés dans des nodules verdâtre donc
le fer est réduit et au trias on va
passer dans des va passer dans un milieu
où les fossiles sont descendants des
milieux beaucoup plus occident et ses
milieux occident ces milieux occident ce
marc sont marquées par des fossiles qui
sont enfermés dans des nodules rouges
rougeâtre donc des nodules oxydé alors
là évidemment j'ai augmenté évidemment
là j'ai augmenter le contraste la
saturation sur ces photos pour que ça se
voit bien parce que sur les photos ça va
ça se voit pas très bien généralement
évidemment mais sur le terrain ça se
voit quand même très très très très très
bien le fait que le changement justement
de préservation entre des fossiles qui
sont dans des nodules verdâtre de fer
réduits et des fossiles qui sont dans
des nodules rougeâtre de fer oxydé
on a j'en ai pas parlé tout à l'heure
mais on a aussi eu une espèce au moins
une espèce qui est typique de la limite
permise trias et lisse trop aux russes
qui ont battu ce tout à l'heure je veux
parler des listes rose aurait dû vous en
parler mais on a le lis trop rude cure
mathus qui est donc une morphologie qui
est intermédiaire en fait entre le gros
et le petit bistrot zaurus donc la
taille est juste intermédiaire entre les
deux hélices trop rude cure mathus ne se
trouve que sur la limite permise trias
donc quand on quand on cherche la limite
permise trias
on sait qu'on l'a trouvé quand on trouve
liste rose aux russes qui ont battu ce
qui est parfaitement intermédiaire dans
taille entre murray et makaga
donc ça aussi ça à notre indice
évidemment faut avoir de la chance pour
tomber pile de
en l'occurrence ici le fossile à côté
duquel on se tenait celui qui se
trouvait quelque part par là
ce fossile et est un bistrot risqueront
mathus donc on a vraiment été très
chanceux voilà et donc cette limite
permise à trias nous conduit à la la
zone d'assemblage avis trop aux russes
la suivante ici donc qui est indiquée en
vert clair donc cette zone d'assemblage
avis trop zaurus c'est le début du trias
le tout tout tout tout début du trias
qui en afrique du sud est généralement
marquée par d'une un milieu très rouge
enfin des sédiments traître et roule
donc on est toujours sur une alternance
marno gréseuses mais la marne devient
très rouge et le grès devient très épais
et on appelle ça la caq berg forme
échelle donc ici c'est très très bien
illustré par segre très épais et ses
marques très très rouge
ça c'est la formation cap béar typique
mais évidemment il ya des endroits où
elle n'est pas aussi typique que ça
hélas donc on a toujours besoin des
fossiles pour confirmer qu'on est bien
dans la canneberge
donc on sait que cette que cette zone à
liste rose au russe commence il ya 252
millions d'années on a des dates qui
proviennent directement de cette limite
par contre on sait pas où elle s'arrête
puis ce qu'elle s'arrête sur une à
conformité donc elle s'arrête sur une
surface d'érosion en fait et donc on
sait pas ce qui vient au dessus en fait
n'est pas directement continue avec la
zona liste rose rouge donc on ne sait
pas quand la zone a10 trop russe
s'arrête exactement mais cette zone la
liste rose russell est très très bien
identifiables par le son contenu en
fossiles donc c'est là qu'on va trouver
liste rose aux russes le dc 90 avec le
détendue
c'est là qu'on va trouver tri naxos dont
le plus connu de tous les signes
montrent du monde et c'est là aussi
qu'on va trouver pro colophon un des
derniers survivants de ce qu'on appelait
autrefois les ânes abside très
reconnaissable à sa petite corne là sur
l'écouté
très très très caractéristique tri naxos
don n'est pas extrêmement abondante il
est abondant il est relativement
abondant mais comparé à la quantité de
liste rose au jeu qu'on trouve dans le
début du trias c'est assez c'est assez
déséquilibré liste rose au russe est
incroyablement abondant il ya deux
espèces au trias des clés vis et maria
maria est le plus petit bien qu'on ne
sache pas exactement il ya une étude
tout récemment qui a montré qu'on
n'était pas vraiment sûr que tous les
mairies iai qu'on a trouvé était pas
encore des juvéniles
il est possible que en adaptant en
s'adaptant à la limite permise trias aux
conditions très très très très très
chaotique la limite terrain trias il est
possible qu'en fait merveille à y est
appris à se reproduire
plutôt que sa maturité c'est que sa
maturité morphologiques en fait que la
maturité sexuelle de mariage arrive
avant sa maturité morphologique
c'est ce qu'on appelle une année au
tennis quand la maturité sexuelle arrive
très avant la maturité morphologique
ça fait partie de ces pédo morphose et
donc il me semble que c'est la néoténie
cela vous le confirmera dans les
commentaires voilà et il y à un autre si
nos ventes qui est aussi relativement
abondant alors au début j'en parlais pas
de galets au russe qui est un autre 6 90
qui ressemble énormément à trignac sont
donc comme il ressemble énormément à
trinec sautons j'en parlais pas jusqu'à
ce que justement on a étudié cette
limite permise trias
notamment avec cédric jurassique et
qu'on se rende compte que quasiment tous
les signaux d'onde qu'on a trouvé là-bas
sont tous des gars les eaux russes est
donc allé au russe il est quand même
super abondant même comparé à un tri
naxos dont et liste rose aux russes on
trouve pas mal de galets sont russes et
notamment dans les premiers instants
après la limite permise trias donc donc
maintenant j'en parle de galets sont
russes c'est un signe aux docks qui
ressemble beaucoup à trignac ce dont
vous voyez qu'il a une comme tri dax
dont vous voyez qu'il a des vertèbres
thoraciques et des vertèbres lombaires
qui n'ont pas la même morphologie que
les vertèbres lombaires sont plates
comme trine axes dont la grosse
différence avec trinh avec ceux dont
c'est la morphologie des d'envoyer les
dents sont crocheter elles ont accroché
en fait les dents puisque tri naxos dont
on n'a pas les dents de trial sur nos
ondes etc uspi de droite chez gas les
eaux russes elles sont accrochés comme
ça et est aussi il ya le palais
secondaire n'est pas encore complètement
fermée chez gallissot russe chetrit
naxos dont vous verrez les deux ces
petites langues
la du maxillaire en fait ne se joignent
pas encore chez galets sur us alors que
chez trignac selon elle se joint donc
voilà et c'est comme ça qu'on a su en
fait qu'on avait plus de gars les eaux
jusqu'au climax aux dons donc maintenant
j'en parle parce que apparemment gars
les eaux russes est bien plus est bien
plus communs en fait que trine axes dont
je m'imaginais en fait que trine
accident était plus commun et on trie
d'accidents et liste rose au risque ce
sont les deux grandes espèces j'ai envie
de dire les deux grands genres et qui
ont permis de retracer les limites du
gondwana
il ya une maison aux russes
historiquement mais après plus tard on a
trouvé liste rose au russe en afrique en
antarctique et en inde
et pareil pour trine accident ce qui a
montré que tous ces continents étaient
liés en plus de l'amérique du sud quoi
et maintenant on a même dû pro colophon
en amérique du sud en afrique et en
australie et en apprendre d'antarctique
donc les pros colophon c'est pareil
aussi il est beaucoup à reconstituer les
limites de secondes ouanna et toute
cette faune là elle était probablement
très très très proches donc on a une
discontinuité
la fin de la zona liste rose aux russes
donc on a une surface d'érosion et au
dessus de ça arrive la zone à sinop
natus la zone a sign up natus qui est
représentée ici donc en vert foncé avec
des pointillés dedans qui est aussi
concentriques toute façon toutes les bio
zone maintenant à partir de la zone
adaptée aux qu'il fallut tout les bio
zones sont concentriques autour du
lesotho et sont de plus en plus
compliquée a observé parce qu'elles sont
de plus en plus proche de la montagne
donc en fait ça devient de plus en plus
raide
donc là ce que vous voyez la raison pour
laquelle les bio zones deviennent aussi
de plus en plus fine c'est parce qu'on
s'approche du drakensberg est donc en
fait vu du dessus ça fait ça voilà enfin
vu du dessus ça fait ce que vous voyez
mes vues en couple ça ferait ça en fait
ça devient de plus en plus raide donc
voilà c'est les affleurements deviennent
de plus en plus compliquées à trouver et
à escalader aussi donc voilà à quoi
ressemble la zone aci nominatif la zone
à 6,90 us c'est vraiment de la meute
stone c'est donc matt stone cessé de
l'argile vraiment cessé de la boue quand
vous marchez dedans vous n'avez pas
l'impression d'avoir affaire à un
affleurement vous avez juste
l'impression d'avoir à faire de la boue
et en fait non si c'est vraiment la saq
ressemble l'affleurement causé de la
boue une boue rougeâtre donc on conserve
cette couleur rougeâtre qui est vraiment
très typique des sédiments qu'on va
avoir après le permien en fait le père
bien le permis a été marquée par des
alternances marno gréseuses houle et
marne était plutôt alors violette marron
ou vert gris bleu voilà mais pas
beaucoup de rouge le plus rouge que vous
avez c'est viol et viol et crade et
après vous arrivez au permien et vous
arrivez au trias hélas au trias le rouge
devient la couleur dominante en vente
donc un climat beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus chaud et c'est normal puisque
l'afrique
encore une fois l'afrique est en train
de bourrer de moules et de bouger vers
le nord en fait il ya toujours cette
dérive des continents qui a lieu
l'afrique continue de se déplacer vers
le nord est donc le climat change
devient plus chaud devient plus arides
là généralement le rouge on associe
plutôt aux tropiques à des sols qui sont
fortement les
suivait alors il me semble que les
géologues qui ont étudié ça ont
reconstitué un climat qui était très
très très contrastées c'est à dire des
saison sèche très sèche des saisons
humides très humide
enfin très humide et très chaude et
saison sèche et froide très sèche et
très froides mais là je ne suis pas
géologue donc je vais rester humble
quant à misano quant aux interprétations
que vous retransmet moi je suis
paléontologues ce qui m'intéresse c'est
les fossiles et elle est fausse et les
sens bien qu'est ce que je pense je
pense que c'est que cet accent moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est les fossiles donc
il ya on a un gros problème déjà avec la
datation de la zone aci nommé natus donc
moi je vais vous la présenter comme
étant du permis du trias moyen autour de
240 9 243 millions d'années enfin autour
de 249 millions d'années pardon mais il
ya des gens qui l'ont date et à 243
millions d'années ce qui l'amènerait
très fortement trias supérieur et ça
c'est ça ce serait un problème ce sera
un énorme problème mais je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi après mais moi je
reste sur une interprétation que la zone
a thing natus est dans le trias moyens
donc autour de 249 millions d'années il
ya une date en amérique du sud pas en
afrique du sud il ya une date qui a été
donné en amérique du sud de couches qui
sont mises en corrélation avec la zone a
thing that us qui donne de 143 millions
d'années d'autant que je vous dise
maintenant pourquoi c'est un problème le
problème en fait c'est que si on place
le la zone aci nommé nature autour de
243 millions d'années au trias supérieur
en fait on va trop on va tomber sur un
événement qui s'appelle l'événement
pluviales caduque hargne 1 et
l'événement pluviales du canadien s'est
encore affaissé un événement
d'extinction un petit événement
d'extinction qui a lieu juste avant la
grande extinction de masse de la fin du
trias et cet événement pluviales du
canadien normalement ça correspond à un
changement phonique important et si la
zone aci nokia tus et concomitante à cet
événement pluviales cardia alors il ya
aucun changement phonique qui a lieu
dans cette zone aci naudinat us du coup
ça rend vain
du coup ça rend très peu probable le
fait que la zone aci nominatif se trouve
à cheval au milieu sur un changement
phonique en fait c'est ça l'idée puisque
c'est une biozone donc par définition si
vous avez une biozone c'est que la faune
reste homogène et si la faune reste
homogène c'est qu'il peut pas y avoir de
changement phonique
voilà c'est donc ça paraît légèrement
circulaire comme raisonnement mais il
faut bien voir que comme je les dis on
travaille toujours en d'une part avec
les datation absolue avec les notations
relative et avec les liteaux
stratigraphie et donc si la litho
stratigraphie change pas et si la silla
ditto stratigraphie ne change pas
sachant que tout ça c'est de la même
formation donc ce les roches rougeâtre
que je vous ai montré ça s'appelle la
borgers dogues formation donc tout ça ça
reste dans la même formation et tout ça
ça reste avec la même faune ben ça rend
le dernier élément moins probants en
fait
sachant que les laits datation absolue
ont aussi le droit d'être fausse et la
datation absolue proviennent d'amérique
du sud si ça se trouve on a mal corrélés
c'est aussi ça aussi on espère que non
évidemment mais ça se trouve c'est la
corrélation qui est pas bonne notre
hypothèse de corrélation n'est peut-être
pas bonne mais bon donc on verra ce que
ça donnera dans le futur peut-être qu'il
y aura de nouvelles datation absolue qui
vont contredire la précédente et qui
vont juste montrer que la précédente
était daube et pour une raison ou pour
une autre ça arrive aussi
ce sont des choses qui arrivent aussi
bref la zone aci nomme hiatus donc du
trias moyens pour l'instant être surtout
caractérisée comme son nom l'indiqué par
la présence de 6,90 du de la ligne et
dessine au goliath
donc les sino d'hondt essentiellement
herbivores à part si nos bna tue celui
même qui ont des grosses qui ont des
grosses process osseux sur le côté des
sur le côté des squames au zoo qui donne
à leur crâne un aspect en w qui donne à
l'arrière de leur crâne d'un aspect en w
quand on les regarde du dessus ou de
derrière donc vous voyez ce cette forme
en w que vous voyez à l'arrière du crâne
de dia des motos ici c'est très typique
d
synovate et c'est dû à la présence de ce
petit flange ici le square mozart
flingue qui est très typique des
synovate
donc on a évidemment si nokia tu ce qui
est typique de cette bio zone qui est le
synopsis carnivores et on a dit à des
maux dont qui est un des multiples
signataires beevor les six nominations
surtout connu pour avoir des arts
vivants mais sinon hiatus est la seule
exception et on a aussi dans cette zone
à six nominés tous les cas de meyer y
forme qui sont des énormes dissimule en
fait généralement énorme dicillo donc
calmés ya quand même un bon g comme ça
je suis la belle bête montcalm et yari
ya c'est de la belle bête mais il y en a
des plus petits comme plat sérias par
exemple il ya des places arrière ce qui
était relativement petit et qui sont
reconnaissables déjà alors créé de
sagittale qui est très très haute à
leurs boekhoorn nasal qui sont très très
large et à leur forum n pinéale qui vu
qu'ils ont une crête sagittale en fait
la crête s'agite à la compresser le
forum npd à l'ailé a poussé fort habile
finale vers l'avant en fait donc il ya
une forme d'entonnoir vers l'avant qui
est très très caractéristique des calmes
et yari forme et de quelle manière il ya
entre autres mais il n'ya pas que
camilla dans le calme et yari forme mais
ils ont tous la même tête en fait les
quatre meilleurs et forment donc je suis
très intéressant à voir et on a les
technos pondi l'oci qui alors les
technos pontife ce sont des amphibiens
et alors les amphibiens ont beau être là
depuis le dernier enfin les choses qu'on
appelle des amphibiens au sens très
large évidemment ont beau être là depuis
la fin du dévonien il était curieusement
peu présent au permien sais pas si vous
avez remarqué la dernière fois mais je
ne vous ai jamais parlé d'amphibiens la
dernière fois et il ya une raison toute
simple à ça c'est qu'on en trouve très
très peu et que le peu de fois qu'on en
trouve ces des séries n'excuse en tout
cas en afrique du sud
on a rarement trouvé autre chose que
rinne et sud rennais su cus oudairies
n'est subsides dernier su guider donc et
ça c'est bon c'est une curiosité et là
d'un seul coup dans la zone aci
nominatives
explosion de diversité des technos pondi
l'on n'en trouve de plein de toutes les
tailles de toutes les sortes
c'est l'arrivée des technos pont deal
stéréo ce pont dit donc ceux qui sont
adaptés à la vie aquatique
on s'est peut-être dû justement à ce
changement d'environnement dépôt je ne
sais pas je ne saurais expliquer et donc
cette zone a thing that us comme je
voulais d'y aller elle est corrélée à
des dépôts qui se trouvent en amérique
du sud notamment parce qu'on y trouve
les mêmes types de cannes mehiaoui forme
voyelles et les cornes nasale très large
le foramen pinéale en forme d'entonnoir
vers l'avant la crête sagittale très
très hot donc ça c'est ici wallace ja
vichy goual astia qui vient de la
formation et chinois la sto qui est
équivalente en tout cas le pense-t-on à
la zone aci naudinat us d'afrique du sud
sauf si la datation sauf s'il ya une une
couille dans la datation et donc les et
on a tendance à dire du coup que les que
les terres abside ont morflé ont
tellement morflé à la limite permise
trias qui se sont jamais relevés les
quatre meilleurs y forme sont là
l'exception très très très très très
notable les camélias reform
on va les retrouver absolument partout
dans le monde donc on les retrouve en
amérique du nord sous la forme de plats
sérias on les retrouve en asie sous la
forme de quelle part à cannes mejia
housse innocad meyer ya aussi on les
retrouve en amérique du sud sous la
forme d' ici ou à acheter donc il ya ils
sont partout les calmer ya une forme ils
ont eu un énorme succès évolutif c'est
calme et yari forme qui montre que les
terres apside en avait encore sous la
[ __ ]
après la limite permise trias ça s'est
pas arrêté après liste rose aux rues
saint lois de la paix on a d'ailleurs
les sea dogs nat les signaux de sino
gold qui ont pris la relève et qu'ils
ont et qui ont eu un succès évolutif
aussi remarquable après la limite permet
un tri yann et la la la l'assemblage à 6
nominatives
c'est pareil a été récemment a été
récemment divisé en trois parties
du moins officiellement divisée en trois
parties parce qu'on l'a on divisait déjà
la zone a thing natus en trois parties
avant mais ce n'était pas officiel
donc ça a été rendue en fils officiel
avec la publication de
2020 dont il a fallu donner des noms à
coucher dehors de ces zones
mais non on connaissait déjà ses sous
zones comme la soude zone hallassou zone
b la zone cei donc c'est ce qui est
représentée ici voilà sous zones à sumbe
sous zone c et puis on a dû donner des
noms comme je disais des codes de
nomenclature de la biostratigraphie
impose qu'on donne un binôme à chaque
sou zone et ça n'est absolument pas
parce que ça n'est absolument pas
indicatif enfin c c'est à peine
indicatif de ce qui se trouve réellement
dans les bio zone donc on va rester sur
sous-zones arras ou zone b sous-zones
c'est juste pour la facilité donc la
première sous zones la zone à la plus
ancienne
donc c'est la zone aci nominatif sous
vous allez sous trouver sinon hiatus et
d'iliad et moudon mais vous ne trouverez
aucun dicillo donc les calmées hier ya
ne sont pas encore là et ça c'est ça
c'est important a noté parce que quand
on a quelque chose d'aussi abondant aidé
aussi diversifiés que les calmes et iai
forme ne pas en trouver ça c'est
peut-être un détail pour vous mais bio
stratigraphique mans ça veut dire
beaucoup et on trouve aussi dans cette
zone sud sous zones à des terreaux sefa
lien donc les terros et fabien qui sont
les petits cousins dessine aux dons qui
ont eu moins de chance que et ses terres
au cfaa lien ils ont tenté la même
aventure que les synodaux en
développement des dingos fonds d'onde
c'est à dire des temps d'herbivores donc
il y ressemble beaucoup
adedy a des maux dont s'était rossé
fallait donc il faut bien vérifier le
palais la forme du palais qu'on ait
voire à la forme du palais les détails
qui distingue les cetc si 90 des
terreaux c'est fabien boy amorphe
ça tient surtout à la présence des
fosses sont orbitaire donc si vous avez
vu encore une fois c'est un prérequis
indispensable je pense d'avoir vu mon
cours sur l'évolution des vertébrés
avant de regarder ça parce que là sinon
vous êtes complètement perdu quoi
latéraux céphale c'est quoi des fausses
ou sorbie terre c'est quoi des fenêtres
orbitaire bref mais bon j'ai pas le
temps de revenir sur tout ça hélas donc
voilà les borgnes amorphes les bords ya
mort sont là mais pas les 10 hinault
donc évidemment si donc bien tu sais
dire des mots durs sont là dans la sous-
zone b donc toujours sinon hiatus
toujours dire des mots dont et
maintenant on a des cannes mais yahia et
on a toujours des bords et amorphe et
dans la soul zone c on a toujours des
canes meyer y forme
on a toujours si longue date us et 10 à
des maux dont par contre les bots riabov
ont disparu et au passage c'est le chant
du cygne des terreaux ses fans c'était
les derniers terreau céphale vivant et
là ça y est ils s'éteignent complètement
donc à partir de là sous zone c de la
zone aci nomme natus l'hétéro ses fans
deviennent complètement éteint voilà
donc et c'est comme ça qu'on fait la
différence entre les trois sous zones si
vous trouvez des bords ya mort vous vous
êtes dans la soul zone ah si vous
trouvez des bords y amorphe et décale
meyer vous êtes dans la zone b et si
vous avez vous trouvé des bords y
amorphe
si vous trouvez pas de bori amorphe mais
décalent meilleure forme vous êtes dans
la zone c et vous allez me dire mais
l'absence de preuve d pas preuve
d'absence j'ai envie de dire ben
échantillon de plus voilà lancé c'est un
commentaire assez classique là que font
les étudiants généralement à ce niveau
là c'est ben oui mais si on trouve pas
mais qui en avait mais quand les a pas
trouvés donc la preuve de l'absence de
preuve n'est pas pointe d'absence s'est
dit autrement
ben là j'ai envie de dire faut que vous
soyez bien sûr que vous ayez regarder
partout vous ayez bien fait votre boulot
c'est ça aussi le jeu de le jeu de
chercher des fossiles le jeu de chercher
des fossiles pour la biostratigraphie
c'est pas de trouver des fossiles c'est
d'avoir cherché suffisamment bien pour
pouvoir dire que quand on n'en a pas
trouvé c'est parce qu'il en avait pas si
vous en avez pas trouvé mais que vous
n'êtes pas sûr d'avoir bien cherché
alors vous n'avez pas bien fait votre
boulot si vous avez cherché du mieux
vous pouviez mais vous avez rien trouvé
alors cette information est bio
stratifié cette information est bio
stratigraphique mans intéressante
je vous rappelle que c'est comme ça
qu'on identifie qu'on est dans la zone
haliotis hinault dont par exemple
on trouve que dalle voilà donc là si
vous trouvez si vous n'avez pas trouvé
de bord ya mort mais vous avez trouvé
pléthore de 6,90 signate et de kanbay
arias vous pouvez faire l'hypothèse
raisonnable que vous êtes dans la zone à
dans la sub sole c'est de la zone à 6,90
us évidemment vous allez aussi à
regarder un petit peuvent aussi l'eau
donc c'est à dire que là si vous trouvez
des dessine aux dons est extrêmement
dérivés par exemple décider au viet
extrêmement dérivés donc pas seulement
10 à des maux dont et si nos bna tus
mais par exemple creek aux dons ou bien
voire même député avec ça encore et bien
voilà vous avez vous allez faire
l'hypothèse que vous n'êtes plus haut
dans la stratigraphie xi vous trouviez
des signes nets plus primitives plus
primitif comme lambert jr et rire à
colon qu'on trouve dans les sous zones a
et b voilà et si vous voulez savoir
encore une fois si vous voulez savoir
comment on fait la différence entre
dessine au budget primitif et dessine au
câble dérivés il faut aller voir mes
vidéos sur l'évolution des thérapies
mais en gros ça tient à l'adaptation à
l'herbe ivory on voit un gradient
d'adaptation à l'herbe ivory chez cécile
dont tu es plus ils sont adaptés à
l'herbe ivory plus leur dans son large
de plus les diastème sont grands et plus
le nombre de dents sectorielles sont
réduites
plus on est face à des signaux plantes
adaptées à herbivores et maintenant on
est sorti du bo forte
donc là on était dans le beaufort le
beaufort groupe
on sort du beaufort et maintenant on
entre dans le storm burg le stand b
regroupe donc la montagne des tempêtes
stamberg où est donc là on va voir la
volt et nos formations qui est la
première étape du stand b regroupe donc
la formation dont le téno on n'a pas
souvent l'occasion de travailler dessus
parce qu'il ya surtout des plantes en
fête
information montre t know et c'est des
plantes qui se trouvent dans des poches
qui comme vous voyez sont exploités en
plein kg est comme ça donc c'est comme
ça qu'on va chercher les fossiles dans
la formation molteni dans des genres de
poche qui contiennent des plantes
fossilisés qui sortent en petites
plaquettes et c'était très très jolie
fossiles comme vous
ici vous reconnaissez les deux branches
de dhikr oïdium ici vous pouvez voir les
détails très très faim qui sont
préservés par cette montée nos
formations détails qui sont tellement
faim qu'on arrive même à avoir de temps
en temps des insectes quand on est très
très très chanceux mais du fait qu'il
n'y a pas vraiment de vertébrés 1 par
des empreintes de pas de dinosaures
comme vous pouvez voir ici
ben cette mode techno formation on a un
peu du mal à la date est donc l on sait
qu'elle est quelque part entre le milieu
du trias et le et le début du trias
supérieur mais on n'a pas alourdi des 2
2 quand elle date exactement cette
formation était neuf
donc on passe comme n'y a pas vraiment
de vertébrés pour faire de la
biostratigraphie on passe directement à
la formation suivante qui est la
formation elliott dans laquelle on va
trouver dans laquelle on a deux zones
d'assemblage la zone ascal et nos dom
torride est ce qu'on va voir tout de
suite et ensuite la zone am a suspendu
donc l'information elliott s'est pas le
beau caillou que vous voyez là ça c'est
la formation clarins la formation
elliott ce sont les couches rouge que
vous voyez en dessous ici elliott
inférieur et vous avez le elliott
supérieur et la zona scalène odonto
hallyday c'est le elliott inférieur de
ces couches rouge donc ça a été daté du
début du trias de 110 à 200 millions
d'années et c'est là qu'on va commencer
à trouver les premiers dinosaures donc
les premiers dinosaures d'afrique les
plus vieux 10 parmi les plus vieux
dinosaures d'afrique et du monde sont
trouvés dans cette dans cette zone a
scanné nos deux leaders en afrique du
sud il ya des dinosaures un peu plus
vieux qu'on aurait possiblement trouvé
en tanzanie mais on sait pas trop si
c'est des dinosaures ou des dinosaures
au move c'est à dire des cousins des
dinosaures donc les plus vieux
dinosaures confirmé en tout cas c'est
parmi les plus vieux dinosaures confirmé
on les trouve la dent dans la formation
elliott inférieur c'est aussi là qu'on
va trouver les premiers synodaux qui
sont très très très très proche des
mammifères donc les pro b naudinat ce
qu'on appelle des signaux de prob et
neuf dates et on va encore retrouvé
quelques très très très très rare calmer
réforme mais ce qui va être vraiment
caractéristique caractéristiques de cet
assemblage de cette zone d'assemblage à
se caler nos deux vitesses c'est
vraiment les premiers dinosaures c'est
les tout premiers dinosaures et le
fossile qui a donné son nom à cette zone
d'assemblage c'est ce cas les no doubt
holiday ce dont vous voyez le seul et
unique crade connu ici donc c'est un
donc on a un peu donné par défaut j'ai
envie de dire fallu lui donner un nom à
cette assemblée john et à cette zone
d'assemblage et c'est celui là qui a été
donnée mais en général qu'on va trouver
céder synovate extrêmement dérivés donc
ce que ce cas les notes aux vitesses et
ce sont aussi les sino dont tu que vous
voyez représenté ici qui vont nous
permettre de corréler cette formation à
d'autres formations ailleurs dans le
monde comme pas ici au brésil on passe
directement à la zone à ma sauce pondi
lui ce qui l est beaucoup mieux
caractériser que la zone haskell et auto
ce cas les lotos vide s 7,7 à zone à ma
sauce pon di luce elle correspond en
gros au début du jurassique
sachant qu'on n'est pas complètement
sûrs d'eux si le contact entre la que
s'il contact avec le trias en fait n'est
pas une discordance en fait une
discontinuité
donc on pense que la zone masos pon di
luce est du début du jurassique donc 200
millions d'années jusqu'à 185 millions
d'années ça correspond à la partie
supérieure de la formation elliott et à
la formation que la rente donc la
formation cloud
ce sont ces énormes roches que vous
voyez là
donc ce sont des clés mais alors ce ne
sont pas des grès de plage c'est à dire
ce ne sont pas des plats de c'est pas du
sable de plage ce sont des grès éolien
donc ce sont des dunes en fait la
formation clar en ce sens de
gigantesques dunes pétrifié et je vous
suggère d'aller d'aller google et ça
tout de suite clarence formation parce
que ça fait vraiment des photos
magnifiques c'est une formation qui est
extrêmement impressionnante cdd
dizaines de mètres d'épaisseur de roche
gigantesque et se sont
et tout ça ce sont des dunes pétrifié
donc là c'est vraiment le genre envie de
dire le l'étape finale de la
réunification en fait du climat en
afrique du sud
à l'époque deux de la formation du storm
et regroupe la dollar maintenant on a un
désert quoi voilà on a littéralement un
désert et ponctuellement qui est
fossilifère parce qu'on a des oasis en
fait qui se sont préservés des oasis
avec des rivières qui coulait les
sédiments dans ces rivières ont conservé
des fossiles avec des dinosaures dedans
donc on arrive à retrouver dès quand
même des fossiles miles elle cet
environnement de désert ils appellent ça
un wet des hearts donc un désert humide
quoi que cela veuille dire j'ai envie de
dire c'est les géologues qui appelle sa
console web des heures le désert humide
et donc cette formation que la reine
soit c'est géologiquement c'est très
très impressionnant très très
intéressant c'est une des rares
c'est une des rares occurrences d'un
désert en fait préserver et puis même ne
serait-ce que touristiquement c'est très
très beau c'est très très beau voilà et
puis en dessous vous avez donc la peur
elliott formations qui sont ces roches
rouges là que vous voyez pas très
différent de la lower elliott qu'on a vu
tout à l'heure pour l'as cannes et la
zone à ce qu'allait le dr ines excepté
que les roches quel con enfin les
fossiles qui sont contenus dans ces
roches sont eux par contre très
différent puisque là où on avait de très
très rare dinosaures dans la dent l'asca
les no 2 dans la zone ascal hello dolly
death et ben là on commence à trouver
une grande grande abondance de
dinosaures la haye notamment le fameux
masos pon di luce lepreau lepreau enfin
ce qu'on appelait autrefois les pros
sauropodes attend c'est un sourire de
maurs basale sous ce qu'on dit luce dont
vous voyez le crâne ici et on trouve
c'est aussi de là que vient sa tarsus
c'est aussi de là que vient et airaudo
taurus
mais les premiers dinosaures d'afrique
qu'on voit souvent dans les livres c'est
de là qu'ils viennent donc ici vous
voyez là la stratigraphie posées côte à
côte avec les âges vous voyez la partie
inférieure du pays hôte représenté en
rouge parce que c'est la couleur des
roches de l'eliott de la formation
elliott
voyez quel la partie supérieure la
partie inférieure en fait sont coupés
ici au niveau de la transition entre le
trias et le jurassique et il y aurait
apparemment un petit petit intervalle
d'une petite discontinuité qui
correspond justement l extinction
juracie compagnie durée une commande une
absence de sédimentation voire même une
érosion en fait à cet endroit là et 7
correspond à la crise en fait la crise
biologique entre le trias et le
jurassique
donc ça fait que on peut étudier la
crise trias jurassique en afrique du sud
mais en connaissant quand même cette
limitation qu'il en manque à vous il
nous manque quand même un bout ce qui
est dommage
s'il est dommage et c'est aussi là qu'on
va trouver les treaty l'odon dans la
zone peur elliott
enfin dans la zone à ma sauce pon di
luce c'est aussi là qu'on va trouver
treaty l'odon treaty l'odon qui est le
l'inde et enfin qui appartient à la
famille des signaux d'autres une des
familles si nos ventes qui va durer le
plus longtemps puisque les derniers tri
kg dont idées vont s'éteindre co crétacé
donc c'est quand même une famille qui a
eu beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de succès
évolutif
après 7 alors la zone à ce cas les 90o
-dès et la zone à ma sauce pon di luce
ce sont des zones d biozone qui ont été
créés très très récemment relativement
récemment en 2020 en fait elles ont été
rendues rendue officielle qu'en 2020 est
la raison pour laquelle on les a pas
rendu officiels plutôt bas c'est tout
simplement ça c'est que la litho
stratigraphie à très très longtemps
suffit à savoir exactement où on était
là
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas besoin de
regarder les fossiles quand tu quand
vous arrivez en face de la formation
clarence vous savez que vous êtes en
face de la formation que la rente
il n'y a pas vraiment de doute là dessus
donc on a on s'est souvent on s'est
longtemps contentée de la litho
stratigraphie dans l'étude
on va dire de cette partie du monde quoi
de la géologie de cette partie du monde
mais après la biostratigraphie a quand
même permis de distinguer une partie
haute de la formation elliott et une
partie inférieure de la formation
elliott dont on a pu déterminer qu'en
fait les différences justement de faune
entre la zone à se caler notons qu il s
est la zone ici à ma sauce pon di luce
et bien cette différence de bio zonation
elle correspond en fait à un changement
phonique majeur qui est la crise trias
jurassique et encore une fois on aurait
pu se contenter de la litho strativa un
film ce serait quand même passé ici
d'une information capitale
la formation elliott permet d'étudier
une crise d'extinction majeur et ça
c'est c'est la glace et encore une fois
on peut faire des bonnes corrélation
avec le reste du monde
massot ce qu'on dit luce en tout cas les
pros sous les sauropodomorphes bazzo les
pros sont pas ce qu'on appelait
autrefois les pros sauropodes étant
retrouvé un peu partout dans le monde
en europe on a platéosaure en nazi il en
looping aux russes en argentine ils ont
musso russes et les leonerasaurus voilà
donc tous ces pros seront pote
permettent de corréler peu ou prou ces
différentes couches entre elles voilà là
c'est vraiment une liste des exemples
d'applications bête et méchante de la
bio stratigraphie de commencer à
appliquer dans d'autres bassins là ici
africains par exemple en amérique du
nord il utilise la biostratigraphie pour
l'heure leur père bien inférieur avec
quand même un peu moins de succès que ce
qu'on a réussi à faire en afrique du sud
voici la chine voici l'europe qui
utilisent plutôt les amphibiens
voici la russie qui utilise des
thérapies seed com en afrique du sud
et voici les limitations du coup je vous
avais parlé dans la première vidéo
il ya des limitations quand même à
l'utilisation de la de stratigraphie la
limitation principal étant quand même
que ça ne donne pas d'âge
ça ne donne pas de date et ne faites pas
dire on paléontologues ce qu'ils n'ont
jamais dit la datation relative ne donne
pas de date
c'est bien la datation absolue qui donne
des dates non arrêtez de dire que c'est
en date les fossiles en regardant
d'autres fossiles ce n'est pas vrai on
date les fossiles avec des datations
absolue et une fois qu'on a des fossiles
attaché à une datation absolue alors les
autres fossiles qu'on retrouve avec ses
faux cils
on leur attribue un âge on n'est pas des
idiots et surtout le raisonnement n'est
pas circulaire de fait
bon bref donc ça c'est la limitation et
comme j'ai pas arrêté de le répéter mais
il faut utiliser les trois aspects la
litho stratigraphie la biostratigraphie
et la datation absolue pour obtenir une
image complète la plus complète possible
de votre section géologique mais les
autres limitations pas c'est évidemment
le rire working comme écrit ici le rire
working étant ce qu on appelle le
remaniement
donc ici par exemple je vous avais à
l'écran un gorgone obtient donc un taxon
qui est normalement purement permien qui
a été trouvé dans du trias en afrique du
sud
donc c'est un gorgone obtient du trias
bon bah pour l'instant la seule
explication qu'on a c'est qu'il a été
remaniée alors le problème c'est qu'il a
été collecté il ya très très très
longtemps ce borg n'obtient et le fait
de l'avoir collectées il ya très
longtemps fait qu'à l'époque il n'était
pas aussi soigneux qu'on l'est
aujourd'hui ils n'ont pas noté beaucoup
de contexte donc on n'a aucune idée de
la taphonomie de ce world obtient et la
taphonomie c'est la façon dont il a été
déposée donc on ne sait pas comment ce
gorgone obtient s'est retrouvé dans le
trias est ce qu'il a vécu au trias
est-ce qu'il est mort au trias est ce
qu'il a vécu au père mia et que le sait
fossilisés et que ce fossile a été
embarqué par une rivière ensuite au
trias parce que je vous rappelle qu'il
ya un changement dans la façon dont les
rivières coulent entre le trias et le
entre le permien trias avant elle
coulait comme ça en faisant des grands
mais ambre et après
le trias elle coule en faisant des
tresses donc les rivières se sont mis à
couler dans des endroits où elles ne
coulait pas avant donc on peut imaginer
que un gogo n'obtient murray fossilise
entre les méandres des rivières du
permien et qu'ensuite quand la rivière
devient en tresses et ben crâne de
gorgone obtient est récupéré par
l'érosion et redéposés en contrebas en
aval et se re fossilise ensuite dans des
roches que nous plus tard on interprète
comme étant trias sic enfin trias est
bon et la morale de cette histoire là où
je veux en venir avec ça c'est que il ne
faut surtout pas séparer la
biostratigraphie de la taphonomie et
normalement les étudiants qui ont ce
cours là aussi en parallèle un cours de
ta fono me pour justement arrivé à
interpréter ce genre d' indices je n'ai
pas de cours de taphonomie à vous
proposer car ce n'est pas moi qui fais
les cours de taphonomie par contre si
vous voulez un cours de ta fono me
donner par mois il y à la vidéo les
théropodes ne chassait pas en meute
la vidéo les théropodes ne chassait pas
en meute
c'est un cours de ta fono mis en fait
est là parce que la leçon principale à
retenir d'un cours de taphonomie c'est
l'endroit
enfin la façon dont on retrouve le
fossile indique que la façon dont le
fossile a été fossilisé
voilà au mieux ça vous indique comment
l'animal qui a donné le fossile est mort
mais jamais de la vie ça vous indique
comment le fossile a vécu enfin comment
l'animal qui a donné le fossile a vécu
donc la vie la mort et la fossilisation
sont trois choses complètement
différentes retrouve vous retrouvez un
fossile et comprendre comment il est
mort
il faut être sûr que le fossile c'est
bien formés suite à la mort de
l'individu est pas suite à un
remaniement
et pour comprendre comment l'animal a
vécu en fonction de la façon dont il est
mort il faut être bien sûr que la façon
dont il est mort est une façon
représentative de la ligue de la façon
dont l'animal a vécu par exemple
c'est facile de dire d'interpréter qu'à
la façon dont un vécu à corail quand on
retrouve ce corail fossilisés
directement sur sa barrière de corail
par contre c'est impossible de
comprendre le mode de vie d'un corail si
on retrouve détacher de cette barrière
de corail
voyez ce que je veux dire donc c'est
important c'est le capital de comprendre
que vie mort et fossilisation sont trois
étapes différentes du processus et que
vous ne pouvez pas remonter à la façon
dont un fossile a vécu dont un animal
fossiles a vécu sans avant avoir
déterminé que la fossilisation est
représentatif de la façon dont il est
mort et que la façon dont il est mort et
voit représentatif de la façon dont il a
vécu et ce chemin là il ya beaucoup de
gens qui font le pont là et qu'ils s'en
foutent
il ya beaucoup de gens qui sautent les
étapes
ces étapes là bas ça s'appelle la
taphonomie voilà donc la taphonomie est
inséparable de la biostratigraphie il
faut comprendre comment un fossile s'est
formée pour pouvoir comprendre pour
pouvoir interpréter sa valeur en tant
qu'outil bio stratigraphique et après si
vous voulez faire en plus des inférences
paléobiologie qu'il faut en plus être
sûr que la façon dont il est mort
reflète bien la façon dont il a vécu
voilà c'est comme ça et c'est comme ça
c'est à cause de ces trois étapes là
qu'on se retrouve avec des trucs du
genre
lucie grimper forcément bien aux arbres
puisque son épaule est écrasée de la
exactement de la façon qu'elle le serait
si elle était tombée d'un arbre
oui ou alors ça veut dire que l'uci
s'est pété la gueule d'un arbre parce
qu'elle ne savait pas du tout grimper
aux arbres
donc le remaniement est l'ennemi de la
biostratigraphie mais c'est aussi
l'ennemi d'ailleurs des interprétations
paléobiologie qu un autre grand ennemi
de la bio stratigraphie ce c'est
justement si jamais vous avez des dépôts
non synchrone par exemple si vous avez
une grande vague de migration on sait
par exemple que à la limite entre les
eaux saines et le lido scène en europe
il y a eu une grande vague d'immigration
des fautes asiatiques vers l'est vers
l'europe
mais cette grande vague d'immigration à
la us elle a eu lieu par petits bonds
parce que l'europe à l'époque c'était un
assemblage deal donc en fait les la
grande vague de migration elle a eu lieu
de façon différée ce qui fait qu'en fait
une faune données en europe de l'est
sera toujours plus vieille que la même
faune en europe de l'ouest
donc en espagne par exemple pourquoi
parce que la faune est d'abord arrivée
par l'asie puis est arrivé en europe de
l'ouest
et comme ces déplacements ont pris des
centaines de milliers d'années
enfin au moins des dizaines voire des
en fait en fait il ya un décalage
donc si vous essayez de corréler en
termes de dates les faunes d'europe de
l'ouest avec celles d'europe de l'est
ben vous allez toujours avoir un
décalage et vous n'allez pas vous en
rendre compte surtout c'est un problème
pour vous ce sera la même faune
donc au final ça veut dire qu'elles ont
le même âge bah oui mais non en réalité
la vague de migration a fait que bell a
fait que n'a fait que la même faune est
plus jeune
en europe de l'ouest qu'en europe de
l'est et ça alors dans le bassin du
caroux on est à peu près sûr de notre
coup quand on dit que toutes les phones
sont à peu près synchrone que les bio
zones représentent des faunes qui était
réellement synchrone parce que le bassin
du caroux c'est un bassin sédimentaire
donc il a beau être très très grand il
n'y a pas de raison de croire que les
faunes étaient séparés par quoi que ce
soit je veux dire pas en tout cas une
échelle significative du point de vue
géologique le lien par contre quand on
essaye une fois qu'on essaie de faire
des corrélations avec d'autres bassins
et notamment des bassins de l'hémisphère
nord comme la russie déjà vous avez pu
voir qu'il existe très peu de taxons qui
sont enfin deux genres notamment qui
sont communs à l'hémisphère nord il ya
l'hémisphère sud à part liste rose aux
russes qu'on retrouve en chine par
exemple il n'y a pas beaucoup de genres
qu'on retrouve à la fois en afrique et
ailleurs
il ya liste rose aux russes je crois
qu'on retrouve en chine et en inde il ya
dicte aux dons qu'on retrouve en chine
aussi et en afrique du sud il ya tri
naxos dont notre inaction on retrouve
même pas dans l'hémisphère nord dont
vous voyez il n'y a pas beaucoup de
genres comme ça qui se retrouve d'un
côté de l'autre et même ça ça veut pas
forcément dire qu'ils ont vécu au même
moment forcément donc faut jamais
oublier que nos corrélation ne sont que
des hypothèses est que des fois ça peu
merdé et on a vu des exemples je vous ai
parlé du pool qui qui à certains
endroits étaient pas dans la bonne
vieille zone
dans la première vidéo et je vous ai
parlé tout à l'heure de la zona sinovia
tuschi a pas le bon âge en en amérique
du sud
c'est pas le se sont pas les seuls
problèmes qu'on a un il y en ad'autres
un des problèmes après c'est peut-être
des problèmes localisés de mauvaise
connaissance de la stratigraphie si ça
se trouve
ou bien c'est juste un problème dans la
façon la méthode utilisée pour la
datation mais faut jamais oublier que ce
sont juste des hypothèses raisonnables
et que y'a rien de graver dans le marbre
et tout ce que je vous ai dis là
aujourd'hui est extrêmement frais ça
vient de 2020 et la dernière la dernière
mise à jour qui avait eu lieu c'était
1995 et avancer à la dernière mise à
jour qui avait eu lieu mais j'ai une
diapo j'ai une diapo là dessus après ben
voilà c'est ça donc voici les mises à
jour donc la dernière
la dernière mise à jour qui a eu lieu
c'est en 2020 la mise à jour qui a eu
lieu avant c'était 1995 donc ces sept
c'est ce tableau là donc j'ai tiré ce
enfin c'est la publication dont j'ai
tiré ce tableau la danse et ismoyo 1995
vous avez une mise à jour en 1981 une
mise à jour en 79 qui compte comme la
même mise à jour il y avait une mise à
jour avant ça en 77
une autre mise à jour en 1970 une autre
mise à jour en 1914 et une mise à jour
en 1906 je vous ai dit que le premier
qui avait mis en place cette bio
zonation c'était six lits dans les
années 1890 et quelques vous voyez il ya
déjà eu un deux trois quatre cinq six
sept mises à jour cette mise à jour en
tout donc voilà voilà la nouvelle mise à
jour
j'ai pas mis les sous zones mais
j'aurais pu j'aurais pu mais voilà c'est
juste pour dire rien n'est gravé dans le
marbre et à chaque fois qu'on a deux
nouvelles dates absolue à chaque fois qu
on a de nouvelles de nouvelles de
nouveaux fossiles qui ressortent à
chaque fois qu'on a une nouvelle
hypothèse qui semble plus probable est
là on met à jour notre système de bio
zonation à côté de ça il faut pas non
plus tomber dans le piège du relativisme
extrême parce que c'est pareil je les
vois les étudiants je les vois faire des
étudiants à partir du moment où on leur
dit y'a rien d'absolu d'un seul coup
tout devient relatif non plus ça fait
depuis 1890 qu'on applique le système de
bio zonation et il marche toujours
aujourd'hui avec des petits réglages par
ci par là mais regardez la biozone
nation qu'on a aujourd'hui donc regarder
la biozone nation sonata pineau canine
une zone à tapis nocé phallus elle
existait déjà en 1914 zona en dot you
dont elle existait déjà en 1906 zone à
kyste et qu'il fallut ça n'existait déjà
en 1906 aussi la zone inde ap toqués
phallus elle existait déjà en 1970 la
zona liste rose aux russes elles
existent déjà depuis 1906 la zone à 6,90
us depuis 1906 aussi dans la zone à ma
sauce pondi lui c'est parce qu'elle est
une ode holiday ce je vous ai dit
qu'elle date de 1920 et la zone a et
audi sino dont je vous ai dit avec elles
datent de 1900
20 15 mai voyez le système de bio
donation faut pas oublier que malgré
tout ça il fonctionne et il fonctionne
très bien même
et notamment comme je le disais en outil
de terrain le titre c'est un outil de
terrain d'une puissance incroyable
vous prenez la route à travers le caroux
comme je voulais faire virtuellement
pendant ces deux séances vous vous
passez devant ces infinité de
d'alternance barnaud gréseuses qui ne
vous raconte aucune histoire
je veux dire à part pour la zone à kyste
est qu'il fallut c'est pour la zone à où
vous reconnaissez les trois les trois
couches de sandton degré ou quand vous
voyez les rippeurs humide donc qui vous
indiquent la zone adapte aux quais
phallus
d'ailleurs la plupart du temps tout ce
que vous voyez c'est une alternance
marno gréseuses a cessé de l'alternance
mardi gréseuses à perte de vue
comment vous faites comment vous faites
pour vous paierez bas vous arrêtez votre
bagnole vous mettez le frein à main
vous allez sur le bas côté et vous
cherchez un fossile et puis le premier
fossile que vous trouvez ça risque
d'être le fossile de plus abondants et
de fossiles de plus abondants c'est
généralement lui qui a donné son nom à
la biozone et vie voilà bon à part pour
un parc pour ce qu'elle est une auto
vitesse mais sinon c'est lui qui a donné
son nom à la biozone et c'est bien pour
ça c'est un petit terrain redoutablement
efficace et ça ça faut pas l'oublier
faut pas l'oublier non plus laly laly
tôt stratigraphie n'est pas un outil
absolue la biostratigraphie n'est pas un
outil absolue la datation absolue est un
outil absolue mais qui est très très dur
à appliquer et coûte extrêmement cher
aussi à appliquer et qui a des résultats
qui parfois ne sont pas fiables parce
que c'est pas parce que la datation
absolue vous donne un résultat précis
que ce résultat est juste faut pas
confondre précision et justesse
vous pourrez avoir une date extrêmement
précise et pourtant qu'elles sont
complètement fausses
comme vous pouvez avoir une date qui
n'est pas très précise avec une grosse
marge d'erreur mais qui est plus proche
de la vérité
bref donc
donc il faut jamais perdre et vous devez
additionner ça aussi du coup à la
taphonomie les grands 4
le père le fils et le saint-esprit et 1
mais voilà les grands 4 voilà c'était là
biostratigraphie du caroux donc qui
conclut le grand cycle
j'ai envie de dire delà de la
paléontologie des vertébrés sud
africaine dont qui inclut la
paléontologie des vertébrés celle des
thérapies site celle des mammifères et
donc maintenant le grand chelem jarlett
dire la biostratigraphie du caroux
j'espère que ça vous aura plu
la semaine prochaine nous nous
retrouvons nous quittons donc
complètement cette fois là le caroux et
nous parlerons d'évolution humaine avec
l'évolution du cerveau humain à la
semaine prochaine